اغلقت مراكز الاختراع ابوابها بعد يوم
الانتخابيه توجه فيه الناخبون الاختيار
اعضاء البرلمان الجديد وهي محطه الرئيسيه
من محطات خريطه الطريق التي اقرها الرئيس
التونسي خايس سعيد
وتزامن مع انطلاق عمليه فرز الاصوات اعلنت
الهيئه العليا المستقله للانتخابات نسبه
المشاركه التي كانت في حدود ثمانيه فاصل
ثمانيه بالمائه وهي نسبه المشاركه الاضعف
على امتداد استحقاقات الانتخابيه منذ
الثوره
ولكن ان نقول مخجله جدا
في الموضوع هذا يستحق نظر لانه اذا كان
نشوفه وانتقدوا
في النواب الذين دخلوا البرلمان في سنه
راي اخر ومبادره جديده
نحن نطلب ان يرحل من الموقع الذي يحتمله
بغير حق وعلى غير وجه شرعي والمطالب بان
يتولى هذا المنصب
لفتره انتقاليه وجيزه
كاظم السامد من كبار القضاه المعروفين
بالاستقامه
والمعروفين بالنزاهه
وبالاستقلاليه ليدير
انتخابات الرئاسيه النافذه
اما الرئيس قيس سعيد فقد وصف بعد مشاركته
في الاختراع على الانتخابات بالفرصه
التاريخيه
وقال انها تمثل قطيعه مع مناهاب البلاد
ونصبوا انفسهم اوصياء على الشعب التونسي
يوم تاريخي لكل المقاييس
تم تحديده هذا الموعد
وتم احترامه بالرغم من كل العقبات تعتبر
الانتخابات التشريعيه احدث حلقه في سلسله
الاجراءات الاستثنائيه التي اقرها سعيد
وسبقها حل مجلس القضاء والبرلمان واصداره
تشريعات بمراسم رئاسيه
جديده عبر استفتاء الخامس والعشرين من
يوليو في انتظار انتخابات الغرفه الثانيه
للبرلمان مجلس الجهات والاقاليم
انتخابات الرئاسيه مبكرا عباره تكاد تكون
القاسمه المشتركه الابرز لردود الفعل
الصادر عن مختلف الاطراف السياسيه في تونس
بما فيها تلك المؤيده للرئيس قيس سعيد
الذي وصف الانتخابات بالتاريخيه بينما
راها معرضون نقطه تحول اسقطت عن الرئيس
مشروعيته الشعبيه تونس